اهلا بكم قالت روسيا ان قرار الاتحاد
الاوروبي برفع الحظر عن تسليح المعارضه
السوريه قد يضعف فرص مؤتمر جناف اثنين
الذي كان مزمعا عقده الشهر المقبل
وجددت موسكو تمسكها بتزويد دمشق بصواريخ
اس 300 في مقابل القرار الاوروبي الذي
اشترط عدم ارسال سلاح الى المعارضه قبل
الاول من اب اغسطس نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي
نناقشه في محورين رئيسين ما حجم المتغيرات
العمليه التي يمكن ان تترتب على القرار
الاوروبي ورد الفعل الروسي
عليه وكيف سينعكس هذا القرار وما جره من
من تداعيات على المسارين السياسي والعسكري
في
سوريا رفع الاتحاد الاوروبي اذا حظره عن
تسليح المعارضه السوريه لكنه لم يقرر في
المقابل تسليحها او حتى يدعو اليه بل ان
الاتحاد الذي ترك ذلك لاراده اعضائه
يقررون منفردين طالبهم بعدم فعل ذلك ان
فعلوه قبل الاول من اب اغسطس المقبل على
الجانب الاخر رات روسيا في الخطوه
الاوروبيه استفزازا استدعى ردودا جديه من
جانبها من بينها ارسال صواريخ متقدمه الى
النظام السوري توعدت اسرائيل بالتعامل
معها حال وصولها الى الاراضي
السوريه خرج وزير الخارجيه البريطاني ويام
هيج من اجتماع بريكسل المارثون
منتشيا لقد وافق الاتحاد الاوروبي على رفع
حظر الاسلحه المفروض على المعارضه السوريه
والابقاء على بقيه العقوبات على سوريا
القرار ترك غصه في حلق دول عرضته بشده
وابرزها النمسه والسويد والمانيا باستثناء
فرنسا وبريطانيا لا ترحب اغلب دول الاتحاد
بفكره تزويد المعارضه السوريه بالسلاح
لذلك قرار التسليح سيكون فرديا ويفترض الا
يدخل حيز التنفيذ قبل بدايه اغسطس هكذا
قيل قبل ان ق هيك ان بريطانيا قد تقدم على
ذلك قبل هذا التاريخ وان فعلت فلن تكون
وحدها المعارضه السوريه نفد صبرها من
الوعود الدوليه الشفهيه بدعمها كما تطالب
منذ اكثر من
عامين لا يمكننا الانتظار الاجتماع المقبل
للاتحاد سيكون في اغسطس اننا نخسر ارواحا
كل يوم موسكو ايضا لم تنتظر انتقدت قرار
الاتحاد الاوروبي واعتبرته عاملا لا يساعد
على التحضيرات الجاريه بش شان مؤتمر جنيف
اثنين ثم جددت حرصها على تسليم نظام الاسد
شحنه صواريخ اس 300 والمفارقه ان موسكو لا
ترى في تسليحها النظام السوري عاملا
يتعارض مع جهود البحث عن حل سياسي لانهاء
سفك
الدماء نعتبر تسليم الصواريخ هذه عامل
استقرار ونرى ان اجراءات كهذه تردع الى حد
كبير بعض العقول المتحمسه في التفكير
بسيناريوهات يت ذ فيها النزاع منحا دوليا
بمشاركه قوات
اجنبيه كان سوريا ليست الان ساحه حرب
بالوكاله تشارك فيها اطراف اجنبيه بشكل
منظم او فردي لم تاخذ الثوره منذ عسكرت
منحا اخر بسبب اطراف خارجيه لها حسابات
خاصه تصفى بدم السوريين المجتمع الدولي
الذي يعيد بمؤتمر للسلام لم يتفق بعد على
موعده وبتسيح المعارضه قد لا يفعل شيئا
فحرب سوريا فعلا لا تشبه اي حرب ومن قال
انها بين سوريين فقط فقد جانبه
الصواب لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
موسكو الدكتور عباس خلف عضو الاكاديميه
الروسيه للدراسات
الجيوسياسيه من لندن بروفيسور فواز جرجس
رئيس مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط في جامعه
لندن من اسطنبول سالم عبد العزيز المسلط
عضو الائتلاف الوطني لقوى الثوره
والمعارضه السوريه وعضو المكتب التنفيذي
للمجلس الوطني السوري اهلا بكم جميعا ابدا
بضيفي من موسكو الدكتور عباس خلف دكتور
كيف تفسر لنا الاعتراض الروسي على هذا
القرار الاوروبي وهم اصلا يعني لم يقرروا
التسليح وانما لم يمدد حظر
التسليح بصراحه موسكو اليوم بالرغم من ان
قرار الاتحاد الاوروبي به بعض الثغرات لكن
موسكو كانت
منزعجه وادانت هذا القرار بابشع الكلمات
وعلى على الاعلى المستويات سوا على مستوى
وزير الخارجيه ووكيله وكذلك على مستوى
رئاسه الجمهوريه
ويب موسكو ترى بان
دعم المعارضه المسلحه التي تعتبرها هي
عباره عن
عصابات متطرفه لمجموعات اسلاميه ولا
تعتبرها كما يعتبرها الغرب هذه ملاحظه
مهمه بانهم محررين و وقوى سلام ولكن ترى
بهم رجال صابات وقطاع طرق والى اخره ولهذا
السبب ترى في في دعم هذه المجموعات
المسلحه خرق للقانون الدولي وقلب نظام حكم
طيب وكن دكتور في مقابل هذه في مقابل
هؤلاء من من تراهم روسيا ارهابيين هناك
لجان شعبيه و تصنف ضمن ميليشيات توظفها
الحكومه السوريه لقمع الناس وكما قمعت منذ
البدايه المتظاهرين وهم ايضا يقمعون
باسلحه
روسيه نعم موسكو ترى هذه الرؤيه الروسيه
انا لا اريد ان ادينها او ادعمها هذا ك
هذا ما تراه موسكو وعلينا ان نحترم كل
الاراء كما يقال وموسكو ليس
فقط ذهبت الى
ادانه الاعمال العدوانيه والعسكريه التي
تسميها هي بالطبع بل ذهبت الى دعم حليفها
ب كل انواع الاسلحه والعتاد والتسليح وهي
ترى
بانها تحافظ على الامن والاستقرار وعلى
وحده وسلامه اراضي سوريا بينما ترى في
اعمال المجموعات المسلحه بانها عمليه لقلب
نظام شرعي قائم في في دمشق في دمشق فلهذا
السبب نرى ان الموسكو كانت ممتعضه
بالاضافه الى ان رات في هذا القرار بانه
توقيت اللئيم لانه يدلل
على على خطط ونوايا مبيته لافشال لافشال
مؤتمر جنيف اثنين مؤتمر الى التاثيرات على
مؤتمر جنف اثنين قبل ذلك اريد ان توقف مع
دكتور سالم المسلط عند موقفك دكتور لناحيه
هل القرار الاوروبي
اصلا برايك مفيد الان للمعارضه طالما كل
هذه ظروف محيطه به اي تاجيل التسليح حتى
ولو لم يمدد الحظر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته حقيقه
يعني ننظر بايجابيه لهذا القرار القرار لا
شك سيفيد
وسيمكن يعني ثوار سوريا والجيش الحر من
الدفاع عن انفسهم من الخلاص من مما تراكم
علينا من غزات من
الخارج تحدث الاخ من موسكو
بانه روسيا تعلمون يعني قرار روسيا هو
قرار سابق بضخ الاسلحه لهذا النظام
وتسليحه لكن
السؤال يحلل لروسيا ان تمنح السلاح لهذا
النظام لقتل اطفالنا ولتدمير مدن سوريه
ويحرم على السوريين الدفاع عن انفسهم نامل
يعني حقيقه هذا قرار جيد نعتبره ونرحب به
ونامل ان يكون له يعني ويكون له فارق على
الارض
السوريه لابد ان ايضا ينظر للجانب الاخر
يمكن
ان روسيا وايران تتخذ من هذا القرار عذرا
وتضخ كميات اكبر من السلاح لسوريا من انهم
ضخوا اكبر كميات من الاسلحه المتطوره وما
زالت بوارج روسيا على الشواطئ السوريه تضخ
سلاح لهذا النظام وايران تدعم مندوبيها
وغزاها الموجودين الان يحاربون يقتلون
بالشعب السوري اي لا بد ان يكون هناك فرق
في هذا وسمعنا حتى من اي فرنسا قالت انها
لن لن تنتظر حتى
شهر اب اغسطس ل تسلح ستبدا اعتقد نامل من
الدول الشقيقه والصديقه ان تبدا بهذه
الخطوه هي خطوه طيبه وخطوه جريئه نامل ان
نرى ما يمكن هذا الشعب من الدفاع عن
اعراضه والدفاع عن حرياته دكتور فواز جرجس
روسيا ترى بان هذا القرار الاوروبي ياتي
بمثابه صب الزيت على النار
ويخفض من الامل في توقعات المبنيه على
مؤتمر السلام المزمع عقده ان عقد ما
رايك في الواقع المهم في رايي في قراءتي
ليس انتقاد روسيا لقرار الاتحاد الاوروبي
برفع حظر الاسلحه عن المقاومه السوريه
المهم
هو في اعلان روسيا على انها سوف تمضي قدما
في تزويد الحكومه السوريه بمنظومه صواريخ
اس 300 والهدف الرئيسي الحقيقه هو الغاء
مفعول صدمه القرار الاوروبي هذه نقطه مهمه
للغايه ولكن اس 300 دكتور صحيح ان ليس
هناك علاقه مباشره اس 300 كان اعلن
عنها صفقه صواريخ الاس 300 كانت روسيا حكت
عنها قبل قبل هذا بعد صفقه اليخون لا بس
ال لا
لا الان الان قالتها وبصراحه كان هناك نوع
من الغموض اليوم تحدثت القياده السوريه
الروسيه انها سوف تزود الحكومه السوريه
بهذه المنظومه وهذا القرار اليوم هو رد
مباشر على لالغاء مفعول الصدمه المهم
الحقيقه بغض النظر المهم والملفت والقراءه
المتانيه للموقف الروسي تقول انها استثمرت
رصيدا هائلا في النظام السوري بانها مستع
مستعده للمضي قدما في الدفاع عن هذا
النظام بانها لن تقف مقوف الايدي اذاء اي
تدخل خارجي وهذا القرار وهذه التصريحات
اليوم للقياده الروسيه هي موجهه اصلا
للدول
الغربيه وتحدثت عن عن العقول الرؤوس
المتحمسه اي قرار للتدخل ومن هنا الرد
الاسرائيلي وبعض الردود الغربيه ولكنني
بالنسبه لقرار الاتحاد الاوروبي الهدف
الرئيسي كما تعلمين للاتحاد الاوروبي هو
استخدام هذا القرار كورقه سياسيه ضغط على
القياده السوريه من اجل التفاوض بجديه في
مؤتمر جنيف اثنين ولكن يعني ليس لم يتخذ
قرار بعد بتسليح المعارضه مع انني اعتقد
بان قضيه تسليح المعارضه اصبحت مساله وقت
لا اكثر ولا اقل وان اهميه هذا القرار
الذي اتخذت الليله الماضيه هو الحقيقه
يعني
وضع الاليات ووضع الجمهور البريطاني
والفرنسي وال الراي العام العالمي في معنى
معين بان قرار تسيح المعارضه هو مساله وقت
لا اقل ولا
اكثر دكتور عباس
خلف لماذا اذا كما يقول دكتور جرجس سارعت
روسيا الى انها سترد بتزويد النظام السوري
بصواريخ اس 300 اليس هذا ايضا نسف للامل
لمؤتمر مزم
عقده انا اعتقد ان القرار الاوروبي سيدفع
موسكو الى التسريع بتوريد الاسلحه وخاصه
منظومه اس 300 وبالمناسبه اس 300 سوف لا
سوف لن تغطي الاجواء فقط للامن السوري
لاجواء السوريه ولكنها ستكون بمثابه امان
ايضا لحمايه الاجواء للسفن والبواخر
والحربيه الروسيه التي هي الان في زيارات
في زيارات كثيره للموانئ السوريه وخاصه
ميناء طرطوس والقاعده هناك اي ان موسكو بل
ذهبت موسكو هنالك معلومات هنا تتردد في
موسكو بان موسكو ستذهب لارسال غواصات
نوويه تحمل الاسلحه النوويه لترافق
لترافق البواخر والسفن الحربيه الروسيه في
الميناء البحر الابيض المتوسط وهي اشاره
على الى الغرب وال الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بعدم القيام باي عمل عسكري او
او اي تدخل عسكري واليوم وزاره وكيل وزير
الخارجيه قال بان منظومه صواريخ اس 300 هي
من اجل منع اي تدخل عسكري قد تقوم به بعض
الرؤوس الحاره او العقول الحاره كما سماها
ولهذا السبب ذهبت موسكو الى اعتقد
ان القرار الغربي والقرار الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيدفع موسكو الى الاسراع
وبالمناسبه كلا الطرفين يريدان ان يعزز
موقف حليفه في الى مؤتمر جنيف في
المفاوضات ولهذا السبب اعتقد ان قرار
الاتحاد الاوروبي هو
قرار يعني دعم
معنوي معنوي
ولربما يكون في المستقبل قرار يعني حقيقي
وتورد الاسلحه ولكننا امام سباق تسلح
حقيقي وامام صراع ايرادات واعتقد ان موسكو
جاده وانا ذكرتها من قناتكم المحترمه ان
موسكو اخذت طريق اللا عوده في دعم حليفها
في دمشق شكرا لك ساعود اليكم ضيوفي الكرام
فاصل قصير نناقش بعده اذا مستقبل الاوضاع
في سوريا في ضوء هذا القرار الاوروبي وما
تبعه من تداعيات نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا جديد اهلا بكم في في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش تداعيات قرار رفع الحظر عن تسليح
المعارضه السوريه على الوضع في البلاد
اعود الى ضيوفي السيد سالم المسلط كان
يقول ضيفنا من موسكو ان القرار الاوروبي
قرار معنوي حتى الان وهنالك بعد فتره
سيكون هنالك سباق تسلح وموسكو جاده في دعم
حليفها النظام
السوري الى اي
حد المعارضه الان في موقف ايضا يعني خطوه
الى الامان ولكن فقط
معنويه اي يعني الكل يعلم وتعلمون ان
روسيا لم ينقطع تزويدها هذا النظام
بالسلاح ضخت الكثير من الاسلحه ولا تحتاج
يعني حقيقه اي قرار مثل هذا حتى تزيد وانا
حقيقه اقول انهم سيستخدمون كعذر لزياده
انما
اي روسيا اي سلمت افضل ما عندها من اسلحه
الى هذا
النظام الصواريخ البالستيه هذا ليس بجديد
طيب بالنسبه للقرار الاجديد ليس لا لا ليس
بجديد روسيا روسيا وايران نعم تسلح يعني
دون توقف وتسلح افضل ما لديها اعطت لهذا
النظام لان النظام روسيا لها ربما مصالح
لكن ايران يعني لها فكر تريد ان تطبقه على
الارض بالسلاح باي ثمن ك ط
ايض امام هذا الواقع الذي تشير اليه وتسمي
ايران ايض الى جانب موسكو وتقول كل هذا
التسليح ليس بجديد عليكم طيب قابله هذا
القرار الاوروبي وصفه ضيفنا من موسكو بانه
قرار معنوي حتى الان اريد ان اعرف الى اي
حد المعارضه تعتبره ايضا معنويا حتى
الان القرار الحقيقه يعني ننتظر الان يعني
ما يترتب على هذا القرار كيف س يعني تتحرك
الدول سواء الشقيقه او الدول الصديقه بهذا
الاتجاه باتجاه تسليح المعارضه وتزويدهم
بالسلاح حتى وان كان معنويا فهذا سيرفع
ايضا معنويات الثوار في
الداخل دول كثيره كانت تنتظر هذا القرار
لتقوم بمسؤولياتها تجاه الشعب السوري
قرارات كثيره قطعت يعني هذا الشعب الذي
تكالبت عليه كل يعني كل انظمه الارهاب
حقيقه واقولها
بصراحه لكن هو بدايه القرار القرار ما زال
يعني جديد هو خطوه يعني تجاوزوا فيها
عقبات كانت يعني عقبه المانيا هي التي
كانت تعارض هذا الشيء لكن الحقيقه فرنسا
وبريطانيا كان لها جهود كبيره في يعني هذا
رفع الحظر ا لن يبقى هذا القرار فقط
معنويا انما
سنجد تنفيذه قريبا جدا سنجد على الارض
ايضا فارق كبير بين ما كان وما
سيحصل يعني حتى هذه اللحظه ثوار سوريا
وبامكانيات محدوده انجازاتهم حقيقه مشرفه
استطاعوا ان يتصدوا لكل
الغزات يعني المقاوم الذي جاء يعني من
لبنان هي هي دوله شقيقه ونعتز بها لكن ان
ياتينا ان تاتينا قوات زرعتها ايران هناك
وتاتي باسم لبنان فهذا حقيقه صعب جدا
تعلمون جميعا ان سوريا احتضنت المع
احتضنت المقاومه عندما كان اسمها مقاومه
لكن الان جاؤوا الى سوريا كغزال لقتل
ابناء سوريا وتدمير مدن سوريا طيب فهل فهل
يمكن الصمت على ذلك دكتور فواز جرجس هل
كما استخدم التعبير الدكتور عباس خلف سباق
تسلح هل هذا الكلام عن التسليح سواء عدم
تمديد رفع الحظر من قبل الاوروبيين او
الاس 300 من قبل الروس يعزز اوراق كل طرف
في اثناء التفاوض في المؤتمر
انعقد في الواقع يعني احد النقاط الرئيسيه
التي حاولت بريطانيا وفرنسا ان تقنع
حلفائها في الاتحاد الاوروبي كان ان ان
على الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يمكن المعارضه
سياسيا و يعني يواز المعارضه سياسيا ويعطي
للمعارضه دفعه معنويه وسياسيه من اجل
الحضور مؤتمر سلام في جنيف اثنين ومساعده
المعارضه على المشاركه في مؤتمر السلام
الولايات المتحده كمان نقطه مهمه للجمهور
العربي وراء الكواليس لعبت الولايات
المتحده دورا مهما في اقناع بعض الدول
الاوروبيه برفع حظر الاسلحه عن المعارضه
السوريه ا والملفت ان صحيح ان الولايات
المتحده اليوم يعني امتدحت هذا القرار مع
ان اداره باراك اوباما ما تزال متردده في
تقديم المساعدات العسكريه للمعارضه
السوريه ا النقطه الرئيسيه التي اريد
ايصالها للمشاهد العربي بان القرار
الاوروبي وان المساعده الامريكيه الهدف
الرئيسي هو الحقيقه هدف من اجل الوصول الى
حل سياسي يعني لا الولايات المتحده ولا
بريطانيا ولا فرنسا تريد تمكين المعارضه
المسلحه من احراز الحقيقه يعني عمل ميداني
او يعني حسم عسكري على الارض الكل يتحدث
عن حل سلمي الان وسياسي ومن هنا هذا
القرار هو الحقيقه يجب ان يفهم من انه
قرار يمهد لعمليه السلام لمؤتمر السلام في
اواخر الشهر القادم وهكذا ما تنظر اليه
القيادات الاوروبيه والقياده الامريكيه
يعني باختصار هو قرار عسكري
لمقاربات طبعا هو هو في الواقع الحقيقه
ورقه ضغط سياسيه استخدامها ضد النظام
السوري هو القراءه انا اعتقد قراءه خاطئه
لان القياده السوريه كما نعرف لن تتجاوب
مع هذه الورقه الضغط القياده السوريه الان
و واعي تكرار يعني جمله اصبحت الان
الحقيقه ما نشهده في سوريا حرب بالوكاله
حروب بالوكاله بكل ما تعنيه هذه الكلمه
بغض النظر عن مواقفنا من الجهات الاقليميه
والدوليه هذا الصراع لم يعد صراعا داخليا
بين النظام السوري والمعارضه السوريه هذا
صراع اقليمي ومن هنا ه الدبلوماسيه
الروسيه والامريكيه الان جديه لدرجه كبيره
محاولت لتذليل العقبات امام مؤتمر السلام
قدمت الولايات المتحده تنازلات مهمه
للقياده الروسيه وخاصه قبولها بعدم تنحي
الرئيس سوري قبل المفاوضات ومن هنا
القياده الروسيه اجتماع البارحه اجتماع
وزير الخارجيه الروسي مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي كان الهدف الرئيسي هو التنسيق
لانعقاد هذا المؤتمر ومحاوله الحقيقه
قراءه الاطراف التي تشارك فيه وتزل
العقبات في هذا الصدد ا دكتور عباس خلف
بدقيقه دقيقتان دقيقه لك ودقيقه لسيد
مسلت لاحظنا بان الاوروبيين قالوا لا
تسلحوا ان كنتم ستسل الحون قبل اب اغسطس
وكانها تريد اعطاء فرصه لجناب اثنين بينما
روسيا ام فورا قالت اس 300 الى السوريين
من اذا يعطي فرصه للسلام الاوروبيون اكثر
من الروس هكذا
يبدو اعتقد ان الاور ان الاوروبيين
والامريكان لحد الان هنالك هذا التردد
الذي شاهدناه والتوريث الذي قامت به
للمعارضه السوريه ودفع ودفعتها الى هذه
المواجهه غير المتكافئه اعتقد ان موسكو هي
لا تزال تملك باوراق اللعبه وتملك
اي وتملك القياده قياده العمليه السياسيه
ولهذا السبب
نراها القرار القرار الاوروبي كان لمصلحه
موسكو لتعزيز قوى حليفها بينما لا يزال
الغرب والولايات المتحده بخجل ووجل
يترددون هنا وهناك واعتقد ان موسكو لا
تزال الرؤيه واضحه اكثر عندها شكرا لك
اختم معك سيد سالم المسلط اذا كما يقول
دكتور عباس خلف الرؤيه اكثر وضوحا عند
الروس وهم اقوياء اكثر ولذلك سارعوا الى
اعتبار القرار الاوروبي استفزاز وقالوا اس
300 في المقابل هل تعتقدون في المعارضه ان
موسكو و من خلالها النظام سيكون موقفه
اقوى في جناب
اثنين
لا اعتقد
ذلك حتى هذه اللحظه وان صرح يعني حتى وزير
خارجيه هذا النظام بانهم سيحضرون مؤتمر
جنيب
لكن لا اعتقد ان موقف هذا النظام سيكون
قوي لا يقوى ابدا بروسيا ولا يقوى ابدا
بايران تعلمون ما هو وضع هذا النظام على
الارض الان وضعه ليس كما كان عليه ولا
يسيطر على الاراضي السوريه الا على جزء
بسيط منها الحقيقه اي يجب اولا واقول عن
المعارضه
ا نريد ان نعرف ماذا يحمله اولا
جنيف هل يحمل للشعب السوري خلاصه من هذا
النظام ام انه يحمل بصمات روسيه لتكريس
هذا النظام واطاله عمره ا شكرا لك وباي
حال بانتظار معرفه موقف المعارضه اصلا من
المشاركه في في جناب الاثنين ومن هو الوفت
شكرا جزيلا لك السيد سالم عبد العزيز
المسلط عضو ائتلاف الوطني لقوى الثوره
المعارضه السوريه حدثنا من استنبول ايضا
اشكر ضيفي من موسكو دكتور عباس خلف عضو
الاكاديميه الروسيه للدراسات الجيوسياسيه
واشكر من لندن بروفيسور فواز جرجس رئيس
مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط في جامعه لندن
وبهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج م وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
اللقاء